deux roues qui se touchent et le château
de cartes s'effondre un policier
imprudent décalé par rapport à la
barrière qui prend une photo le landais
nelly scène le frappe alors de plein
fouet
derrière ces jalabert tueur plus aussi
pleine phase l'agent des forces de
l'ordre bien panneaux publicitaires
alors nous avons découvert que le métier
de coureur était un mec est dangereux
c'est vrai premier diagnostic
le policier souffre d'un enfoncement du
thorax
cet homme s'appelle ernzer c'est un
luxembourgeois
il ya une fracture du crâne il vivra
mais il ne pourra plus jamais a bicycle
également touchés dans l'accident
l'allemand baldinger et l'italien
périgny souffrent de traumatismes divers
cantons français de riddes et il a
plongé dans le ravin et s'est blessé
gravement à la cuisse gauche
et comme des charognards sans aucun
scrupule
nous avons filmé des hommes à la dérive
des naufragés et ça c'est le vrai visage
et tour de france